Friday Polly's a new bite and Chris
Cuomo phones home in some woke movie
reboots go down in flames joining us
with all the details Raymond Arroyo Fox
News contributor alright Raymond you
have some breaking Biden news yes I do
congratulations are in order for Joe
Biden his son Hunter was sued back in
August by a woman lawyer who claims she
had a relationship and a child with
Biden's son she was a student at George
Washington University when they met
Hunter has denied both the relationship
and paternity but the results of a court
mandated DNA test are in for this we go
to our special field correspondent you
are the every child is a blessing lore
but Joe Biden didn't seem too pleased
when our Peter Doocy
asked him about his new grandchild
reporting piling out of Arkansas no
that's a private matter hmm classy if I
were Joe Biden that wouldn't be throwing
the word classy around when all hunters
wandering hunters denied the
relationship and never meeting her right
so now not only did he meet her had a
child with her now if if you can't trust
him on his own flesh and blood how do
you trust him on I didn't speak to my
dad at all about varèse you know the
Biden's have been trashing Trump for
being a reality star it looks like
they're making their own foray into
reality here the Maury Povich Show now
Laura during the impeachment hearings
David Holmes who worked as at the u.s.
Ukrainian embassy testified that he
overheard a conversation between the
president and ambassador song Glenn
he claims he could hear the president's
voice despite the fact that the call was
not on speakerphone
president Trump disputed this idea in a
tweet writing my hearing has been always
been great never have I seen a person
making a call which was not on
speakerphone and been able to hear or
understand the conversation
I've even tried it to no avail
try it live so CNN's Chris Cuomo tried
it live with his mama very interesting
theory from our president he's never
been able to hear a phone call when it
wasn't on speakerphone from anybody so
let's just play with that for a second
mom can you hear me so if I were holding
the phone here I'm with Danna Bosch she
just say hello mom I can't hear your
mother Chris he couldn't get
confirmation if you're gonna pull a
stunt like this Laura test it out first
and make sure everybody can hear by the
way he had his phone on speaker that is
not what the president said so it's this
is this was a disaster for Chris can you
open the glove with OJ must acquit mrs.
Cuomo is a bit like one of those callers
into your radio show where they're
listening to themselves on the radio ah
so huh god bless yeah but it's hard to
hear it it is hard to hear it well
because you're not listening to the
phone you're listening to yourself
something like I kind of like when moms
and dads come on shows combined Irvine
are no longer with us but it at some
point it does become a little he could
have just done the same thing with Dana
Bash right or head on producer you call
in a little bit like daytime TV mumble
might consider a second career Laura as
a product demonstrator ah Elon Musk over
at Tesla might even have a job form must
conveyed the new Tesla cyber truck the
other day its armored windows and walls
our bulletproof must insist it go ahead
throw something at it yeah
well maybe that was a little too hard he
said they're gonna fix it in post this
is another this is another experiment in
real time that you have in product test
a four you've got it you've got it
rehearse these things or don't go out
there this guy by the way musk lost
seven hundred and twenty million dollars
as a result of that didn't the
Kardashian daughter make six hundred
million or she's selling six hundred
million in her makeup company she twenty
two right there have been a string of
flame outs at the box office in recent
weeks and they all seem to involve
reboots now what is going on this has
been happening for some time but it's
only picked up steam and how bad they're
flailing well Laura the audience maybe
finally tiring of these endless remakes
and reboots Elizabeth Banks second
Charlie Angels reboot versus the second
movie franchise with Kristen Stewart
cost fifty million dollars to produce it
had an opening weekend of twenty-one
million dollars a flop now part of the
reason is this was a woke feminists
Charlie's Angels now you remember the
original with Kate Smith Farrah Fawcett
it was a show the eyes could watch there
was action there was beauty this new
iteration was a little different these
women can do anything just because they
can doesn't mean they should
[Music]
director Elizabeth Banks explained her
vision for the reboot this way I was in
love with the idea of watching these
professional women at their job this
movie is not about the boyfriend that
they don't see enough the dog they're
not feeding you know the mom they're not
calling our audiences don't want to be
talked down to or demean particularly
men or attacked which is what this
franchise did it also runs afoul of the
original vision of the series and the
movies which was beautiful women who
could defend themselves but they were
part of a team but they used their
beauty and their Wiles to get their way
not always their fists the very idea
that they're throwing 300 pound men
through a plate-glass window this is the
audience that we have our own ingram
angels but your Charlie it's always so
it's really Ramon's it but you're real
high angle hello hello angles we do this
is what happens with the production no
but it's just it's kind of the whole PC
thing just ruins cinema
it ruins day it also ruined the TV later
the new Terminator rebound with Linda
Hamilton that was also a kind of
feminist reinvention of the old
franchise bombed lost hundreds of
millions of men have a great weekend
great to see